ich habe heute ein thema mitgebracht was
eigentlich nicht von mir stammt sondern
von ihnen den film nacht zuschauern es
besteht ja die möglichkeit dass man uns
themen schickt und es haben sich
studenten an uns gewandt an die
filmredaktion und zwar haben sie angst
dass sie im märz ihr studium abbrechen
müssen hier sehen wir eine eine meldung
erhalten haben von der universität
tübingen und in der mensch steht es geht
um das fach zahnmedizin steht die
universität tübingen ein brief an die
studenten impfpflicht für zahnmedizin
studieren de mit dem beschluss zur
impfpflicht von personen in heilberufen
ärzte pflegende etc sind nach
rechtlicher prüfung des bmg auch die
studierenden der einschlägigen
studiengänge von der universität
betroffen eingeschlossen dies bedeutet
dass bis zum stichtag im märz 2022 alle
zahlen medizinstudierenden geimpft sein
müssen wenn sie das studium fortsetzen
möchten habe gestern abend mit einem der
betroffenen studenten oder studentinnen
ich werde hier nicht das geschlecht
sagen auch telefoniert und ich muss ganz
klar sagen dass das eine schande ist
dieser druck der ausgeübt wird ich habe
den heute die universität kontaktiert
selbstverständlich und die haben ja auch
geantwortet das statement klingt hier
etwas anders als ne mail an die
studenten zitat es ist nicht vorgesehen
studenten zu exmatrikulieren die
medizinische fakultät folgte der
rechtlichen einschätzung des
bundesministerium für gesundheit das
auch im patientennahen bereich des
studiums einen coup 19 impfpflicht
vorgesehen ist die fakultät empfiehlt
daher ihren studierenden zu ihrem
eigenen schutz sowie zum schutz der
patientinnen sich impfen zu lassen alle
weiteren schritte bedürfen einer
gesetzlichen grundlage ich möchte dass
andere sie übersetzen sollten die iren
pflicht durch die politik kommen werden
die studenten ihr studium ab märz 2022
nicht mehr fortsetzen können und das ist
für mich ein grobes und
ja das hört sich schon etwas anders an
was die uni damit teilt sie empfiehlt
die impfung ich weiß gar nicht worauf
sie sich beziehen beim der bmw heißt ja
gesundheitsministerium dass das
gesundheitsministerium solche
richtlinien herausgegeben hat ist mir
neu das würde ja für andere
na gut es gibt ja auch keine impfpflicht
in krankenhäusern bisher für
pflegepersonal das ist alles erst
vorgesehen und das muss gesetz wir
rechtliche einschätzung und die m alle
weiteren schritte bedürfen einer
gesetzlichen grundlage dass er raus
geschickt aber schon stand sie können
ihr studium nicht mehr fortsetzen
oder sie hat alles so verteilt dass sie
alle so versteckte geschichten die die
unsauber sind mir fällt immer wieder auf
dass diejenigen die die spaltung der
gesellschaft beklagen über corona selber
das allermeiste tun um sie zu spalten
denn natürlich entzündet sich an so was
ein konflikt in dem studiengang und es
fühlen sich studenten unter druck
gesetzt und
ich wünsche mir nur dass
muss man einfach karl lauterbach sagen
dass der wechsel im
gesundheitsministerium wenigstens in
dieser hinsicht ein wenig klarheit und
rechtliche sauberkeit bringt denn das
ist alles unsauber als zweifellos eine
sache verstehen immer wir machen jetzt
der union vorwurf dass sie etwas
ankündigt dass möglicherweise passiert
damit gewisse studieren dass sich
vorbereiten können ob sie sich impfen
lassen oder möglicherweise anderen
studie machen also ich verstehe nicht
allein die frage alles verstehen
oder die ebenfalls aber meine
persönliche meinung heilberufe natürlich
eine impfpflicht und hinter uns haben
mediziner ziehen dazu ja das ist ja kein
studium das ist das in meinem studium
dann die haben ja kontakten ordnet man
es ist ja kein
philosophiestudium gold ist wie im
vertrieb für halbes jahr geben ich hoffe
dass eine beratung bekommen haben ja das
wird ja schon druck ausgeübt die gibt's
ja noch gar nicht sagen man informiert
die studierenden ja umsatz aber dies
bedeutet es bis zum stichtag im märz
2022 alle zahnmedizin studieren in
geimpft sein müssen wenn sie ihr studium
fortsetzen möchten das klingt nicht mehr
wie ein empfehlen rennen grundlage
werden das steht nicht in der männer
stehen deren stellungnahmen der uni an
mich von der gesetzesgrundlage stand in
der mail an die studenten nichts
dann sollte die uni in der tat
nachbessern aber der fakt an sich das
heilberufe im studium wo es dann auch
kontakt mit patienten gibt ihr wissen
dass wir alle in arzt zum glück darf er
nicht nur die theorie dann irgendwann
der patienten ran sondern da hat man ja
vorher dann auch schon gewisse
praktiker semester cetera pp ist doch
vollkommen klar dass du wenn die
impfpflicht kommt dass das auch für die
studierenden meinung kann man sein wenn
die impfpflicht eben da ist aber die ist
noch nicht da und es wird so getan in
vielerlei hinsicht als gäbe ist die
schon die umkämpften werden ja auch so
behandelt als gelbe led schon die gibt
es aber noch nicht die haben sich alle
nichts zuschulden kommen lassen diese
studenten die umkämpften auch nicht ich
bin dreimal geimpft bin sehr für impfung
aber der umgang mit ungeimpften ist
unter aller kanone in dieser
gesellschaft es geht nicht so weiter
muss ich sagen
politiker sie werden ja auch abstimmen
sie sind mitglied des bundestages sie
werden eine lehrperson seien die
abstimmen wird über die impfpflicht
keine sorge ich will das nicht denn hier
zu sagen was sie wollen aber ich würde
sich schon fragen finden sie es denn
richtig wenn studenten die die sicher
zum beispiel uns gewandt haben
vielleicht ihr studium nicht mehr
fortsetzen dürfen da platzt ja auch
lebensträume also ich finde es total
richtig dass sich die studenten an euch
wenden und ihr vor ihren punkten
standpunkt klarmachen denn das klingt
sehr sehr schwer wiegen ich weiß noch
nicht auf welcher rechtsmäßigkeit diese
äußerung existiert ob das überhaupt
verhältnismäßig ist und es gibt ja immer
wieder gründe warum sich junge menschen
noch nicht impfen lassen sei es
medizinische indikation und so weiter
und so fort und es gibt ja auch unis in
deutschland wie beispielsweise die uni
greifswald die hat sie anders gemacht
die hat im präsenzunterricht einerseits
zweig vorgeschrieben aber bei ausnahmen
von einer schwangerschaft oder eben
medizinischen gründen können die
studenten dennoch die
universität besuchen und bei praxis
einsetzen die beispielsweise der
zahnmedizin gilt weiterhin 3g dort
natürlich vielleicht auch zunehmend je
nach infektionsgeschehen auf mit
testungen aber es gilt 3g und das ist
schon der punkt wo wir erst mal abwägen
müssten was hier gemacht wurde ist schon
ein stück weit junge menschen in eine
enge zu treiben und gerade die junge
menschen sind es ja die besonders stark
neben verschiedenen weiteren
personengruppen unter der pandemie
gelitten haben ich kann nur sagen viele
haben nach dem vierten semester kennen
noch nicht mal ihre mit kommilitonen
oder haben noch keine studenten party
besucht und ich bin ja ingenieurin
natürlich weiß ich wie schön ist es auch
das studentenleben zu genießen hat zu
pauken einerseits aber auch das zu
genießen und deshalb finde ich schon
etwas schwer wiegend was hier gemacht
wird weil eben auch die gesetzliche
grundlagen heutiger konsumenten
aber man kann darauf hinweisen ist es
mag wohl richtig sein aber das ist
erster punkt wo man sie eher in die enge
treibt ihnen ja schon die angst schürt
dass sie möglicherweise ihre
heißgeliebte studium worauf sich so
lange gewartet haben dann nicht die
person mit der ich gestern telefoniert
habe der war ganz klar okay also bis
märz muss ich mich impfen lassen oder
ich fliege raus weil so ließ sich auch
die mail das heute war die rückfrage als
ich die uni gefragt habe dann die
antwort aber die mail ist natürlich
druck und wenn sie das studium
fortsetzen möchten die rechtliche
grundlage ist noch gar nicht da aber
christa dieses studium mir auch noch
nicht so lange her du hast der gerade
seinen abschluss gemacht wie wir das
muster sehen also ich bin tatsächlich
auch deiner meinung es ist wirklich so
dass wenn wir hier jemanden ausgrenzen
dass man da einfach ein problem hat weil
jeder hat das recht auf sein studium und
da bin ich einfach dafür dass wenn ich
mich frei entwickeln möchte und eben das
immer im studium vor habt dann darf ich
mich da nicht ausgrenzen lassen und wenn
es maßnahmen gibt wie jetzt zum beispiel
dass man in der praxis bereichen dann
sich eben auch testen darf und dann
trotzdem teilnehmen darf dann finde ich
es auf jeden fall eine ja erstmal eine
eine lösung man sagt denn die richtung
kann es gehen aber diese dieser
ausschluss und diese ausgrenzung finde
ich definitiv falsch sie haben den
begriff 3g erwähnt ich stimme dem sehr
zu 3g wäre völlig in ordnung übrigens
für alle gesellschaftlichen bereiche wie
ich finde weil das niemanden ausschließt
die leute müssen sich halt so fernsehen
beruf nachgehen sowieso jeden tag testen
lassen dann steht auch fest dass sie an
diesem tag jedenfalls nicht infiziert
sind das sind sie sogar sicherer als die
vor monaten geimpften von die ja auch
die träger von infektionen sein können
und 3g sollte glaube in der ganzen
gesellschaft gelten und solange keine
impfpflicht vorgeschrieben es sollte
dass das maß aller dinge sein
ich hoffe noch ein bisschen darauf dass
die fdp die liberalen lösung mit 2g
irgendwie widerspricht weil auf dauer
darf es das nicht geben und jens spahn
hat er schon gesagt dass wir zum ganzen
nächsten jahr noch geben gebe gott dass
es nicht der fall ist kann ich nur sagen
ja die gewissensfrage ist hierbei der
impfpflicht schon angekündigt jeder
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages
kann nach seinem eigenen wissen und
gewissen abstimmen und sicherlich gibt
es grad bei den liberalen da viel
diskussionsbedarf auch wie man sich
positioniert eben bei freiheit eines
unsere grundprinzipien ist in unserer
dna als liberale und deshalb ist es auch
so notwendig verantwortung geht aber
einher und deshalb ist es auch so
wichtig da die diskussion einerseits
einfach mal offen zu führen aber dann
nimmt die diskussion ja noch kein
ergebnis vorne weg und ich weiß es
verschiedene partei kollegen und
kolleginnen und kollegen den letzten
tagen durchaus schon in eine ecke
gestellt wurden was sie ja so noch nicht
geäußert haben sie haben sich lediglich
die äußert offen für eine diskussion zu
sein und ich denke der respektvolle
umgang miteinander auch in einem
kritischen themen muss auch das
ermöglichen dass man hart diskutiert und
dann auch die besten weichen zu finden
wir müssen schon einmal nur um den satz
zu machen wenn wir mit der liberalität
in der freiheit an jeden einzelnen wenn
das so wunderbar funktionieren würde
dann wären wir nicht da wo wir wären
offensichtlich sind die brasilianer ja
schon deutlich weiter mit 90 prozent im
clip bei uns deutschen ist es
offensichtlich noch nicht richtig kann
ist thema ist ist allerdings sehr ja in
der tat die haben die kurve bekommen
nachdem es nach dem 11
ja es hat aber hinbekommen
münster studieren wer vergleichen ich
habe münster studiert das war keine
arroganz partys der zahnmediziner gibt
es wirklich sehr schade weil das waren
wir die besten partys die zahnmediziner
gemacht haben das muss dann auch gesagt